you think it didn't break my heart to
see them march him out there and call
him the new captain america
this isn't what steve wanted oh my gosh
so what do you want me to do call
america and tell them i changed my mind
oh boy we got a lot of that in this
episode this is your official spoiler
warning for
falcon and the winter soldier episode 2
i'm carlos bustamante
and this is et canada's nerd alert
this episode starts with john walker the
new captain america
by every metric this is a guy that on
paper is qualified for the job
a highly decorated exceptionally skilled
and experienced soldier
and though he doesn't quite have
america's ass
he does get a hero's welcome by the
american public with
an interview on good morning america in
the middle of a football stadium it's
like
the most american thing ever the thing
is at first glance
jon seems like a decent enough guy he's
just trying to do the job
and he knows he's got big boots to fill
there's no real reason to hate him
yet but i'm sure we'll get there the
unsettling news of a new cap is the
catalyst for sam and bucky's reunion
bucky is mad that sam would give up the
shield and though sam has his reasons
it's a conversation that's gonna have to
wait sam's going on a mission to track
down the flag smashers in munich
and find out what their deal is bucky
decides he's tagging along and just like
that
you get classic marvel team-up
shenanigans i love it
[Music]
problem here is these two just can't get
along sam is cool and collected and
bucky is hot-headed and not quite as
shall we say
graceful as superhero as his high flying
counterpart
[Music]
when the guys catch up with the flag
smashers they discover the group is
stealing what looks like vaccines
and appear to have taken a hostage
appear being the operative word here
as bucky quickly finds out you okay
a very cool highway truck top battle
begins and as our heroes are getting
their asses handed to them
they get an assist from the new cat and
his partner
lamar hoskins these two also get their
asses handed to them
as the flag smashers aren't normal
people or androids
or aliens or wizards they're super
soldiers
and before we go on a moment of silence
for redling
[Music]
in their first non-fisticuffs related
meeting john and lamar aka
battle star valstar
stop the car i know i know i personally
can't say it without whispering
galactica
immediately after is that just me anyway
they tell sam and bucky about how the
government is handling the massive
population of people coming back from
the blip
who are classified as refugees john and
lamar's job
is to keep things stable violent
revolutionaries aren't usually good for
anyone's cause
usually save other people with the
resources well we got a lot of resources
this right here lays out how sam and
john have different outlooks on their
roles
as a soldier john has only ever worked
for the government and he was
hand-picked
to be their new symbol sam has been a
soldier too but he also knows what it's
like
to be considered an enemy of the us and
his best pal steve wasn't exactly a
model american soldier
when he was picked to take up the shield
on top of that in the real world
this also immediately refers to how
those in power treat regular people
who stand up for their own rights this
is interesting when you consider who the
flag smashers are
as they're seen by many people around
the world as heroes
you could say they're being positioned
as villains in this series but that's
one of the great things
about how the mcu works even when
they're fighting the good guys
there's typically something about their
motivations that ring true
now with a bunch of new super soldiers
running around the mystery of how they
got here leads bucky and sam to an old
acquaintance of the winter soldiers
isaiah bradley if i met you mean
i wiped your ass then
yeah while america has been mourning the
loss of steve rogers and going gaga over
john walker history has forgotten isaiah
bradley who is the
black super soldier unlike the adoration
and fanfare that the blonde-haired
blue-eyed captain americas get
isaiah was put in prison and essentially
tortured by his country after his
service to them
his identity and heroic deeds known by
only a few
isaiah in the comics has a slightly
different story but it's a great one
check out the book truth red white and
black so you're telling me
that there was a black super soldier
decades ago and nobody knew about it
hey what's up man
is there a problem here no we just
talked now right after their meeting
with isaiah we get a scene that's
all too familiar with police hassling
sam and not bucky
only stopping when they realize who sam
is after bucky gets arrested we get to
see the awesome dr raynor take him
and sam through some couples therapy and
though it's mostly played for laughs
it does get to the heart of what's going
on with these two right now and steve
and his shield are right at the center
of it that shield
that is that is everything he stood for
that is his legacy he gave you that
shield and you threw it away like it was
nothing
so maybe he was wrong about you and if
he was wrong about you then he was wrong
about me
can you accept that i did what i thought
was right
finally like a kid with a crush who just
can't take a hint
john walker tries to enlist sam and
bucket aid him in going after the flag
smashers
then throws a hissy fit when they turn
him down
you see sam key i'm calling them sam
kinab because honestly i just don't want
to say sam and bucky every single time
sam key have their own ideas about how
to find these new super soldiers
they're going to start with a guy who
knows a thing or two about super powered
mercenaries
helmet zemo okay then
we're gonna go see zemo what could
zemo's connection to the flag smashers
be
do you think he still has any sway over
the winter soldier and will we get red
wing
back from the dead let's talk about it
in the comments below i thought this was
a great episode but
we want to hear from you as always
coming back next week for another recap
and hit that subscribe button for even
more nerdy and
not so nerdy videos i'm carlos
you